[Applaudissements]
et avec ça rentre dans la cour des très
grandes chaînes politique
moi ce que j'aurais voulu c'est un débat
contradictoire et au cours du film après
la vérité et il est sur i télé c'est pas
sur des meetings et présidentielle dit
j'ai tout filmé ou presque c'est le coup
presque qu'il y aurait peut-être intérêt
à les traits de mercenariat je voudrais
ladite jamais paru si gilles avait fait
un documentaire comme ça lui le rayon
une distance par rapport à son sujet sur
alors que là il n'y a aucune distance
puisque c'est une équipe à son pied
s'est pas mouillé comme quelque chose
mais ça fait des bons du même quelque
chose de si jeune et si les mairies au
si vous n'aimez pas vous perdez pas déjà
donc et au passé mais valve est
complètement de la vie de valérie moi
j'ai aimé le film la conquête
j'ai envie de les voir mais je pense
qu'ils ont fait ça parce que c'est une
amie vous le venez de le dire qu'ils ont
dû dire si c'est bien ou pas si c'est
pas bien en face c'est bien ça le rend
sympathique
j'arrive pas je pense terminer les
villes sont sans voix non j'aime aussi
la pression des relèves salut les gars
de beauté